bravo très bonnes réponses
bon autre chose maintenant continue quel
est l'animal qui court le plus vite
aleri à lyon c'est pas le lion à
l'autruche va très très vite mais c'est
pas l'autruche
le liège en relief ça va très très vite
aussi mais c'est un lièvre c'est pas le
cheval 2010 et le guépard et à quelle
vitesse courtil 50 kilomètres à l'heure
non plus vite comme ça presque 110
kilomètres à l'heure le guépard et
l'animal qui court le plus vite il qu à
110 kilomètres à l'heure
ces familles là non alors une autre
question maintenant un coup rhinocéros
est un coriace et ross à votre avis à
quelle vitesse il peut courir se fit
gilchrist en passoire il faut une
réponse directe à 45 kilomètres à
l'heure et oui un gros rhinocéros sa
cour à 45 kilomètres à l'heure c'est
formidable nous tiens vous êtes là cela
dit je vous n'auriez pas vu casimir par
hasard non là c'est ennuyeux on a été
obligé de commencer à jouer sans lui et
vous savez quand il est pas là bas c'est
nettement moins amusant on écoute et on
continue quand même une autre question
quel est l'animal qui saute le plus haut
mireille jeudi gilles le plus marqué
c'est ça y est offert sous thil
dominique l1 mettre non plus aux quatre
médecins peu trop ils sont à trois
mètres de haut et oui le puma et
l'animal qui saute le plus haut il fait
des bonds de plus de trois mètres de
haut extraordinaire et chez les oiseaux
il ya deux champions de vitesse ex-aequo
qui sont ils
non c'est pas l'autruche et les oiseaux
et rognait à l'hirondelle ça coûte ça
vole très vite mais c'est à l'hirondelle
non je vous le dis à vous c'est l'aigle
impérial et le faucon pèlerin
voilà et quelle est leur vitesse sa
fille ça marche très très très très vite
alors là c'est vraiment un conte bien
validé 160 kilomètres à l'heure est-ce
que vous rendez compte il faut que
l'aigle impérial et le faucon pèlerin
vol à 160 kilomètres à l'heure et
casimir est toujours par là mais ça
commence à m'inquiéter savez les
emprunts vous allez jouer et moi je veux
voir ce qui se passe d'accord on
recommence à plus tard à tout à l'heure
je les tue c'est pour me poser des
questions sur la vitesse du guépard et
le poids du mammouth alors là parce
qu'aujourd'hui les légions t'emballe pas
tant elle pas la voilà donc tu n'aurais
pas vu casimir aujourd'hui ah non c'est
vrai j'avais pas fait attention
en fait il devrait être là il savait
bien qu'on faisait un jeu mais oui c'est
pas du tout normal ils disent pas si
quelque chose de ces écoutes
je ne voudrais pas avoir l'air de faire
des raconta mais il aurait dit aux
facteurs qu'il était très malheureux
parce que nous étions très aimable avec
monsieur du snop sous prétexte que c'est
un homme de qualité mais en fait c'est
ridicule je sais bien que c'est pas vrai
je pense qu on est on est poli avec
monsieur du snap c'est vrai mais notre
préféré c'est notre casini c'est évident
c'est évident pour tout le monde mais
sans doute pas pour lui mais si
succeptibles ont mal compris il a l'air
de penser qu'on ne les aime plus pourvu
qu'il est ce parce qu'encore pendant
plusieurs jours
mais cheikh hamid ben rabah casimir
c'est toi on peut pas ça alors qu une
surprise mais dont mais les bravos avec
casimir ma très chère julie je vous
serais très reconnaissant de bien
vouloir m'appeler môssieur casimir chez
nous les gens d'autorité c'est une
habitude à laquelle nous restons très
attachés
ça alors pour une surprise des dons les
bravos casimir qui nous a fait une bonne
farcissez c'est vrai tu nous as
bienvenus mes chers amis le fascine
nullement d'une passe le casimir
grotesque et lourdaud que vous avez
connue n'existe plus
vous avez devant vous un nouveau casimir
qui depuis aujourd'hui suit des cours de
maintien chez monsieur jacques faisons
aujourd hui et dillon casimir walt tue
vraiment sérieux ouais et alors à un je
veux dire à toute hâte un sérieux quel
dommage qu'il se soit repris un casino
j'en ai tôt ouais et alors ne m'avait
fait autant de plaisir fou de vouloir te
changer nous t'aimons tels que tu es
avec tes petites chansons tes petits pas
de danse et même des collègues mais vous
préférez les gens de qualité mais pas du
tout casimir non nous aimons les gens
tels qu'ils sont sains
nous aimons bien monsieur du snop c'est
vrai mais notre préféré notre favori
c'est toi c'est nathan casino et du le
sait bien mais attention hein hein
casimir authentique son chapeau sans de
papillons hausse en fleuret et sans
canne et son cours de mal qu'à se mettre
aux oiseaux
regarde ce qu'est ce que c'est dit
vous imitez casimir ouais alors
n'importe quel réseau parce que j'ai
compris que tout votre affection aller à
casimir parce qu'il est plus gai que moi
plus simple plus amusant mais maintenant
je saurai troll regardez moi et puis toi
aussi qu'à finir mais qu'est ce qui vous
prend tous les deux directs ou les dires
de me retenir
vous avez compris nos vaisseaux de la
peine mais après tu y as c'est la
première fois que je me mets en colère
aurait la première fois
[Musique]